[Music]
both your guns are in so you can notice
[Music]
right actually I'll show you this in
third grade ready keep a lid on your
tricks Marie she's gonna see that dude
so what so what you know he's sick
realize I had to do to get her to marry
me
leave it on the rocks for months
I'm sick of reloading our marriage
please no more reloads at my house so my
fault you smoke enough Freddie fine
we're getting our brewski only pretend
that this conversation never happened
take the buff for their guy they're here
right yeah we're not gonna win over
Zurich lousy [ __ ] we're not using it
well why did you back to the zoo clear
we're not gonna bring which one of you
idiots practice bazooka
hey Freddie
okay hot dogs
yeah sure
[Music]
wait can you help me get the TV working
I was trying to put the game on the
batteries are dead
can you reload them well I tell you to
throw these matters away to the trash
but that's so good
[Music]
all right sports Freddy I'm just putting
on the game I thought you were putting
on dude she asked me to help how could
you
Niko it's not her fault man no more
reloads fine the sacred promise on your
mother's grave fine under no
circumstances will you ever reload my
house ever again fine I promise I will
never perform another thing gasps reload
in your house
[Music]
relax you got this one man
and now reloading
[Music]
take her promise on your mother's grave
[Music]
reloading
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my here oh I'm fine thanks partner no
problemo I do have one question though
if someone reloads in the woods and no
one's around to see it
is it still tacticool hell yeah it is I
assume you have a package regarding I
have been waiting for the shipment of
drugs and money so we don't have the
drugs or money but you're gonna love
this the hell is this how is this better
than drugs you can get drugs and money
anytime anytime you know right down the
street but what you can't get if this
limited-edition 500 unit only
long-sleeve black t-shirt I mean street
wear and street value check this out
they've never made a jacket before this
is the first jacket they've ever made
everything on the store sells out in
like one day two days somewhat of an
hours gone you see this right here I'm
wearing one of those right now it's not
suppose could hide your own supplying
about it this way you have a shirt on
right now I am sure I've got three
shirts on right now and this shirt right
here could be the shirt that we all have
on right now drugs and money everywhere
but this merchandise will never be
available again you see what I'm saying
corridor digital Tod store